Here's our formula again. Let's assume I have the following the data.
There's an x variable, y variable, and we have four data points.
6 goes to 7, 2 to 3, 1 to 2, -1 to 0, and very quickly we can just look at the data diagram.
In this case, a scatter plot. So here's the x axis and here's the y axis.
And if I plug the data, 6 goes to 7, just about here, 2 to 3, 1 to 2, and 1- to 0,
not surprisingly this data is in fact, linear.
Whatever nonlinear you see is because of my poor drawing skills.
And if you analyze carefully, you already saw that y is always respond larger than x.
So before we apply the formula, let's just quickly guess what b and a would be,
if y is always found larger than x. What are the coefficients of b and a?